that's that really so what like like
what specific policy are we fighting for
equality of all sexes and the fact that
men have certain privileges that of
course women don't we don't have the
privilege of walking in the middle of
the night and not being scared that
someone's going to attack us and
were fighting for equality in those
times and beyond that as well in terms
of you know in the legal world in terms
of
education in terms of uh jobs there's so
many things that so to start men are
more likely to be victims of a violent
crime than women
so um
if like and i don't really know what
policy we'd be fighting for because i
think across the board like i i say
grape on youtube i can't say that
i can't say i can't say r-a-p-e
so i'm gonna say great okay like grape
is illegal murder is legal so all
violence is illegal so i just don't know
what policy we're fighting for because
if you just tell
bad guys don't don't grape or don't kill
like they're not gonna stop but like
marches aren't gonna fix that it's just
law enforcement yeah i agree i i'm an
aspiring barrister so i know that more
than anything it is the legal side of
things that
do need to be put in force more
i guess boldly and
solidly
to in order for us to actually achieve
equality it's not a thing of oh what is
the one policy that's going to make this
work and that's going to that what we're
fighting for there's so many things that
feminism is fighting for and you can't
sort of box that into a certain thing
and say oh what what is the one policy
you're fighting for i disagree with that
it's not it's not it's not one policy
because to me we are equal yeah like to
me in 2022 i don't think we need
feminism because i don't think there's
anything left to fight for
well i would disagree with that and i
think i don't know where the
conversation would go from that other
than to say
that there are so many things
well so i'd like you to like list them
so so if women are at a disadvantage but
matt like because the first example you
gave men are more likely to be victims
of a violent crime so we're not
disadvantaged in that regard like men
also are afraid to walk alone at night
in a dangerous area
i take your point
but i think there's a certain privilege
of even us living in the western world
that you won't see beyond
just this island country there's so much
more that we haven't seen
in
uh south asian countries where my
parents originally from from
um african countries from south american
countries and a lot of it is to do with
education there is a clear disparity
between the education of
males to females and you don't see that
because we live here women dominate
colleges
yeah yeah so yeah but we do an advantage
there but do they dominate colleges in
bangladesh do they donate colleges in
india well in any population group it's
never going to be equal like like if you
take okay if you take a group of anyone
it's never going to be 50 50 down the
middle because people have different
things that interest them yeah so yeah
so to me it's like if there's nothing in
their way stopping them from going to
school and and for me i'm specifically i
will sorry i should have prefaced with
this but i'm talking about like england
u.s i'm american and and here there's
nothing stopping us from getting an
education
so so to me like what what's what's
holding us back
i mean
i think about
feminism as it also being intersectional
in this in the sense that i'm talking
about race i'm talking about class as
well socioeconomic divide in this
country
it's so clear okay so i just want us for
this conversation stick to gender
because that that's like what we're
talking about because that's a whole
nother yeah but um because to me like i
just don't see anything holding us back
there's nothing i can't do and like
there are companies that have done um
like google did a study on its employees
because they thought they were paying
women less but when they took into
account the number of hours worked and
the specific jobs that they had women
were making eight percent more and i
could quote you study after study after
study that that shows there's no pay gap
when you take in into the account hours
worked and interest
well
i don't like the fact that you're taking
one study out of i and i would love to
see that you know it bullet pointed and
written down in my own eyes but i don't
like uh just seeing oh from one company
and one this and one that because we
have to look at it in the entirety and
looking at
in the entirety and even for example for
me i'm an aspiring barrister we're all
self-employed what is that what is an
advocate in court they're a lawyer
um
and for example they're self-employed
but in their chambers where they work
they don't have such thing as maternity
pay how are they meant to
fund themselves their cha their families
their children when they don't have
those policies in places and
that's where we disagree because you're
saying oh everything's good happy and
jolly but that's not the case is there
paternity pay no they there's so it's
equal then
i would disagree just because
i mean a woman has to literally shoot
someone out of their vagina
you know what i mean oh gosh it's
raining um
and i you know that is just one example
but what i'm trying to say is that they
we
look at a whole range of things and we
can see quite clearly that it's not
equal
well because like what i'd like to hear
from feminists is like what is the
specific problem and what do you
specifically propose lawmakers do about
it
i feel like it's so hard to you put me
on the spot but it's so hard to just
kind of get it up in my head because
there are so many things wrong i mean i
mean
you know
abortion and healthcare in america
that's
insane i don't want to delve into that
because it's just insanity i would say
compared to here we are blessed with the
nhs but
they can get abortions in america
but in certain states there's certain
conditions and there's certain things
that
had to be in order for someone to get an
abortion again i'm not i don't live in
the u.s i don't want to get
because the one thing like like men
aren't like with women don't if i don't
want to be a mother i can get an
abortion or drive to a state that allows
me to get an abortion but if a man
doesn't want to be a father he can't he
can't he's he's stuck on child support
for 18 years
he can't he can't opt out of being a
father the way that women can opt out of
being a mother i have a question for you
i pray choice of prayer life am i am i
pro-choicer pro-life oh i'm pro-life
yeah i can see you quite clearly um
sorry what was your question so i'm
saying like i i i would say that in in
terms of reproduction men are at the
disadvantage because if i if i get
pregnant right let's say let's see um
there's a guy i get pregnant and he
doesn't want me to keep the baby he has
no say
and on top of that so he he he's stuck
on child support for 18 years
where where me i i can cash a check
there are women that are that are
seeking out hot top individuals like nba
players like trying to get pregnant by
them because the justice system is so
in favor of women like i just have to
get you know i just have to get pregnant
by a dude and i'm entitled to his money
for 18 years
you know what you're
the way you're twisting things is
actually reminding me of how the media
twists everything in the sense like you
take the one percent of the cases that
are happening and i and i want to say i
disagree with the whole nba thing but a
woman's body is her body she can choose
to do whatever the [ __ ] she wants with
that it's not necessarily a guy's choice
to say hey
i bought the baby because i don't want
it no that's that's your bit that's not
your business it's a woman's body it's
my body i'm going to birth but it's his
baby
you're the one that had sex with the
woman that's your fault you you you
fought for having sex with him
no you can't say that just because no
what what you said it the other way
around okay fair enough that i would
take your point but i'm saying
you can't say the whole point of oh just
because the man doesn't want the baby
it's not his body to choose whatever the
hell he wants with it question would you
agree that it's his money his choice so
he should if he says i don't want to be
a father and the woman says i want to be
a mother he can financially
be like do a financial abortion where
he's not on the hook for child support
would you agree with that be in the name
of equality oh i i would if if if that
is an agreement between both parties
then of course
no no where she says i want his child
support and he says
no
like i don't want to give it to you so
should he be because a woman
i have if i get pregnant i have the
option to say i don't want to be a
mother but if i get pregnant he doesn't
have the option to say i don't want to
be a father
so you're asking
so if the woman
says hey i want your money and the guy
says no i don't want to give it to you
oh that would be a difficult one i'll
probably have to give a bit of a think
on that i haven't ever thought about it
and i don't want to give my opinion
without validly sort of backing it up um
so yeah give that a think
because i'm just like this is what i
mean when i say feminism is a hate group
because we only advocate for for women
and in that case which like in my head
it should be pretty cut and dry
because
like if if a woman gets to choose not to
be a mother then a man should be able to
choose not to be a father
i'm gonna go back to the point of view
saying feminism is a hate group i think
that in and of itself
is not what feminism is of course as any
feminist would argue but
how
everyone perceives feminism i guess
that's in their own eyes what they see
on social media but how i perceive
feminism is to be inequality
of everyone equality of sex is of
quality of gender so
it's not the superior superiority of
women which i think that's your angle
into this
i never said women are better than men
it's more so hey i would love to have
the same rights as you
that's literally it to me we have the
same rights if not more especially in
the legal system because men get three
times the amount of sentencing for the
same crime as a woman and right now
we're seeing the effects with amber
heard and johnny depp believe all women
like look look where that got us that
was that was at the cost of of men
because if a man that has privilege and
power that happened to him
what happened to the average guy oh no i
i agree with the amber her try i think
that's a difficult
case to kind of look at just because
yeah um
i know in terms of american law it kind
of makes it easier now for
uh no sorry it makes it harder now for
women to have no evidence or
yeah so i know where you're coming from
in terms of that but sorry
back to your question again would you
agree that the um that in that case
feminism was at the detriment of men
because that was specifically during the
believe all women era
well i don't understand so so my
question is in that instance the amber
heard and johnny depp would you agree
that feminism was at the detriment of
men
because that was during the believe all
woman era oh right yeah um
i wouldn't say feminism was i think
i think in terms of the amber her trust
i would say it kind of routes back to
more the criminal justice system than it
is to do with feminism in in the sense
that
i mean i believe all women
are able to have a voice and
can be a complainant in a case and be
fairly tried it's not the sense of hey
we should all believe her i never
thought hey
we should all believe her we should all
believe him
um but it wasn't in the justice system
like that like you can't say it was like
the justice system because um
like what happened was she got an op-ed
so it was just a matte it was like a it
was a left-leaning magazine that gave
her
an opinion editorial with no evidence
and was able to assassinate his
character with no evidence because we
should believe all women
no that's what i'm saying i can't go too
much into like just because
um well i can't i don't know
insanely too much about it to be fair um
but no i do agree that if there's no
evidence against someone then okay so we
agree on that yeah the one thing yeah
[Laughter]
but again like i said with that it's
very hard because
in terms of that my opinion is just
every every woman every man should be
heard in the justice system in the
criminal justice system and they should
be fairly tried and it's not the case of
amber oh sorry uh johnny depp winning
they both
you know they both had to pay damages it
was more so that johnny depp i was just
awarded more damages it wasn't a
criminal trial so we can't say anything
in terms of that sorry my legal nuzzana
is coming out
so my other question if feminism is
about equality why don't you see women
marching the streets for men to get into
bars for free or for male only fans
models to get the same amount of pay
like we see for sorry i'm sorry like we
see for um the women's soccer team
i think the least of our worries is
about men getting into clubs for free
you know honesty i think there's so much
more that we have to fight for that
that's the most
i don't know fickle thing ever so i i
would say no comment to that just
because that's a ridiculous question
well what about modeling let's take like
the modeling industry it's very much
favorite like women get paid more in the
modeling industry than men but we we
don't see any marches for that where
with the women's soccer team they're
they're
it's a big commotion about them getting
paid the same i think i would revert
this question more so back to again this
being one case scenario so i i don't
know the evidence behind it but i i can
imagine that why women get paid more is
because there's a higher demand for them
but i could also argue oh what's
happening at wall street what's
happening at canary wharf what's
happening at transfer lane who uh
there's clearly a gender disparity there
where i work gosh you would hardly see a
woman at the highest authority or the
highest uh stage in our career
so do you know say that to you as well
so again it's a wrong way do you know
why that is though what do you mean why
why there's more men
because they have more
they have male privilege in the fact
that
they're able to go through life in many
stages without having to worry about
certain things even as like an ethnic
person a woman has to take care of her
family
there are certain barriers that you just
don't see
in
i don't know in like a western world why
don't you say it's women choosing what
they want to choose so if women if more
women choose to be mothers and more men
choose to go after one percent jobs like
why is that a bad thing like why do we
need to fight for equality if women are
choosing what they want to choose that's
not i'm not saying that's a bad thing
women can choose whatever they want to
do men can choose whatever they want to
do it's more so the fact that the the
aspiring women and the aspiring men even
if it was a 50 50 ratio it's going to
end up at the top it being maybe 20
women 80 men because that's just how the
system works i don't i'm saying i don't
think it's the system like my so i'll
give you an example my dad
he's he's in the one percent right in
terms of income but he worked 80 hours a
week my whole life i didn't see him i
don't know many women that want to work
80 hour weeks like like 12 hour days
every single day for 20 30 years like i
think most women have a natural
inclination to want to be with their
family yeah no that's fair enough but
also there are women that are like that
there are women that want to be the top
10 there are women that don't mind
working 80 hour weeks but they don't
have the opportunity to get there in the
first place what so what opportunity do
they not have they're hiring quotas that
specifically they want to hire women
over men
even with hiring quotas i don't
necessarily agree with it because it's
almost so much for
i don't know so much for
i don't know how to describe it other
than it's not really
it doesn't have
oh i don't know how to say it um
i don't know i don't think quotas are
enough is probably what i'm trying to
say so so what would be enough
genuinely giving women the i wouldn't
even say benefit of the doubt but where
credit is true and allowing them to work
their way up the
system really how are we not giving
credit when we hear women's empowerment
all the time i i never hear men's
empowerment
well we need women empowerment in the
world in in this world because
i mean i don't want to keep arguing well
at the same point but obviously we're
not agreeing on this then other than the
fact that women
are disadvantaged in this world and
that's what we're fighting for it's the
equality it's not the superiority well i
i just don't like because i just feel
like you you you keep saying we're
disadvantaged but you don't give me
specific examples of how we're
disadvantaged okay well
i'll have i'll message you on instagram
when i actually have a clear head and
i'm not really extremely heated
okay no worries um do you have anything
any channels you want to plug anything
um
i have an instagram it's at legalnasana
that's l-e-g-a-l-n-i
that's it okay well thank you for
sitting down i appreciate having like
respectful conversations with people
that disagree so i really appreciate you
sitting and stopping thank you okay
more about your view than being mine
okay